in the Norwegian region, after the evacuation of the
population, the
situation is still tense in the blocked
territories, gangs of looters are operating everywhere,
ravines and tarkov,
private military companies have stepped up their activities,
among them are western
dudes representing the interests of the
international corporation ter game, and
also, according to some reports, the Russian
private military company pr the presence of
the latter  restless region is still
not confirmed by the
Russian official authorities
[music] you
say the departure of our group
you are talking about it
may take a long time to
clean up this [ __ ] dargan
[music]
it’s unclear then it’s
still not a reason for a combined arms operation
inside our country
[music]
minus
without girlfriends
while the Scythian is clean
on it for three
guys, leave it
angry and turn us on to me and let
the crops let
me try to eat one leg will be able to
Kharkov unity who knows this
area the Indian bodies of the missing
boys showed a departure from their group
you look and you wouldn’t have to look for anyone
like that  guys, steam up things until the crowd of
our fans has run into normals, there is
someone who he will take whistled brother
so everyone rounds off the city of Gavrikov, they
will start looking for them to get out of here
where is our smut falcon fort falcon
for the boss answer out of the zone go also
take it very
scythian
and where is your minus
I am a marauder  to which you control you are
bad at x0 and
I did this while this campaign with
my trunk went for a walk your unfinished
hour can be anywhere
my septic tank from the live beach - 12 serb 300
your match to chat on the control
serb where now the
wiping firms proud
Petrovich then  under the plaid flew in
to watch the movement our dogs partner
drew to become you can everything is numbly
dry
[music]
gothic so
skiff everything is for you
mouse to the place of the skiff hold back exit it
is known that
I already take all
[music]
this is
[  music]
you know,
I suddenly realized very clearly that
I probably won’t pull such a life, I won’t be able to pretend from one day that
everything is in order,
but that one day they won’t even tell me
when to lay flowers, of
course I can say anything,
even everything again  you will do as you
think you need
yours of course
I just want you to know
and they are one of those who are talking nonsense about how we will
still remain friends
let’s shoot and
show them and it’s not blown away, the men
get ready to move away from the best liturgy
line and the demon of the topic here with a gesture I definitely do
n’t meet anymore,
the men the demon is all
[applause]
there alone in that country with pieces of iron they took off
another one they will crush on Lyoshka you were waiting for you in a
thoughtful bag  the bastards of the
Scythian campaign turned out to be right and if it weren’t for the
luck we would have been up to 5 2 calculation,
our post was provided by the boss to the athletes of
Ferghana by the Scythians, otherwise they think that
the profit from the group for the task I dogs yes
I didn’t have there, but when we
saved the hangar  I was showing off at the beginning
and if I was low, then I wouldn’t be at the
4th athlete now, considering we have a skiff group, but
not at all if you all searched
the result, you need to check a couple more
backup points my boys couldn’t
just like that and now of course I saw the course
[applause]
Exactly at port 250 enters and then
reminds the territory of
civilians is blocked as soon as marauders are
stray part further wonder sometime
always push and stop
cash on the course of hardening today terra grappler
of all fluffy zayd they soar cause kenya
create technologies of tomorrow
then why can’t ours just make
public  the results of the investigations of
what Razin does in reality
because I need weighty
evidence and our type of weightless
politics
[music]
problems at home
should remain under
yes I knew
it also said that only
those who have a place to return to return
poured out, do we have it
right  now you just need no one to
[music]
but what is there to decide
marquis marquis is an otter reception marquis
mark
it is an otter reception nothing hollyak
this is the only place on the route where
my guys could gain a foothold on top it
takes time in moscow shchekin their logic
object  we’ll clean up the puffs
and we’ll just
pass by, and if I’m right if my
guys are there if they didn’t drive the same one
to us on that hangar, I brought out the
demon from the army insert the conversation
the city of the Scythian is right, we have a task and we  we
will carry it out, get ready for
us while there are
no traces of the Scythian group are on fire, let's go jumping
too, the corps
patrol of such minus
this is garbage
[music]
and
then we are
better hidden for the
sake of which we ran away, well,
everything is definitely moving forward,
you can find we put the club
well, the
cycle
and
then
a
eyes
chase
[music]
our departure 2350
latecomers to catch up on foot I
will be as a maple
mother to interrogate the rules everyone knows at
the base no interference
[music]
commander you tomsk connection
loading on board four more hours
spend this time to good use
[music]
bugs and where the birch trees and the group
will be unloaded, you were created
like that
before the year the
seal
yes they say your commander played over to
pick up
[music]
here,
for comfort, the challenge gave birth, repeat we
take you from me for this gut,
no one went like that and  marks of some
weight,
judging by the photo of the lands, it’s been recently still
coming in there, look, there is a file
with you saw
download
for the [ __ ] up employees of the thorens
collaborator, a nerd, but the goal of
our first group is right through the very way,
by the way, there are three of them purely found out about the
company dreams of getting  a
group of Scythians should have broken them back
where they were chained to the campaign,
this is ours, we
press the guy
May why the sailor is the most powerful
in the church for a click
campaign inhale that we found an issue about
what now we are working on a yew, I’m sure that
during this time the antennae have already taken out
Starkov’s case, so  now it’s probably time for us
to go home, but what about the whole that died,
I’m not going to risk my people
to clear your conscience and the demon
mouse,
okay, I’m with you to the exit point and then I
’ll be back,
I myself will get even, let’s go free, you
really
need an answer
losing a
drinker
[music  ]
this is the dumbest place in the target,
it
can pop in and mustaches, like at home
it suits you
[music]
I stay on the chips, but
this two words of the
client starts ubert
he with steel
strong on the territory
guys half a pack of pure let's think you
usually for  to charge
you with a seal
like men so as not to kiss now
we solve an example of a
fire contour minimum wage
move your rolls with your throat and on the partition
a crystal accord
this is years old water bodies of the city of anapa a pot
it's all too smooth when the
circle is modest to drive wildly
it's to create
carbon as my hand says
I come I come with a knife on the go  someone to follow him
on 7
as the bullet passed
[music]
and
I don’t
know
[music]
yes
these
[applause]
you give through the first so you want to
take I will put pressure put on you let
’s
go to you but a
ter barmaleya
[music]
[  music]
[applause]
black
ah
[music]
ah [
music]
hey bro [music
]
wild fan service [music
] [
music]
how's the weather the weather good yes cool
beware thank you try your best
how the environment is here once it's calm
you're more fortunate  than
we stood in reserve for your group already knowing
you can give my fighter
a message from home we will show
[music]
every last time I did a big
stupid thing
and I want you to know that I will wait for
you as long as it takes
we will wait for you
matches
because very soon  we will become a
real family
good afternoon I don’t receive a message on the
phone somehow on the drill please
show them this video and it’s very very
important
[music]
[applause]
that’s what
we were looking for from you
[music]
here
even press reception
water wet
water wet and the password water is wet
during the day Russian [ __ ] password check the
cunning of the
officer on duty is finished call me here
well [ __ ] you where you have to visit
English
about tanks you need a kid will raise or
some passenger
[music]
heard that I will die ubiquitous retail
I want to buy and years from tartar or what are you
a musician on can a qr-code
[music]
I think with my hand
there is nothing [
music]
and who may be interested in the master's HIV
no one should mess with this you are a
serious businessman
[music]
you have  here the machine fell ill due to the fact that
even though Petrosyan died
and what is so important they watched say thank you
for not bent for once again we rotate on the
heroes china also brings a serious
leader in two hours from the radar
here we will see the scene let's not be late
but
warm daggers
so that all the noise  bread,
listen, loner, you don’t care to get out of here,
so you either bosch or scare these
trees and valkyries, I remember,
but I didn’t shoot the civilian
population to your house, then
it’s those in the gossip girl group match
like folders and work of part
you won space cadet  class according to what are all
the box permits that's why I have to
deliver this evidence to my command
or was issued and taken out lowered such put
around brauberg we won't
churicheva today we drive this any
car rental stitched party at recess
yuri sad
[music]
means so as before  I watch three
players backing backing up backing perry graco
hey mike even to the place of sniper leshka
also after the gong
to instill that they didn’t understand how the tanker
truck mike hurst and where to the right to the
right of the children was given to you to
solder yes I don’t know how your favorite
feet where the rights are just in  prague
write t shirt write cheers thomas you take and
this is
also mine give me a coin
slide slide reception
slide brought the slide to the reception through our
caliskan I don’t think it’s
just for the sake of blowing off
an aphorism,
but if this coffee we had a clearing and our
trick failed boris house boris  where does
boris carry you your mother is welcome and you don’t happen to
know where the soul is here is a hobby
where we nishtyachok catching the case won’t drain hey
you are a Nordic and maybe it’s time for you to
slow down the sectarians what do you think we
will help out for you at least immediately from friends
well we haven’t decided what  on herbs, lari knows
maybe something went wrong
[music]
this is 2309
a man came to me to buy a
ticket from tarkov to the mainland
in exchange for luggage on your body
long before your guy
arrange an ass for tarkov
our ministry of defense is quiet  blocking, count the
conversation in just a day, turned into
fortresses of network lara types, you can become,
but after the evacuation of civilians and the
place the whole latitude, the puddings of
the approach 5
is similar to umma.ru, the storm beats next,
but through all his home to the authorities, his
legion of finances
once again the same  time let's work let's
[ __ ] come on let's [ __ ] let's work
dry
listening to
everything now exactly spring
name
work
[music]
well
[music] [
music] follow
me
with forms of water and a number of cards from the film
taken just went to wait 2 x
download maps outside this gate  there is a
loading on the ship
with a conscience call, I can’t even believe that we
will soon tell
where these checks for a year in the village come from to me at the
exit
they sing
couples
.
yucca toshiba
testicle
yes forgot and stop yes love
for breaking through tiu.ru
[applause]
seconds it's already 500 ah
ah ah
have to have says sit and I'm a hare
who
publishes varnish and try
eyes
and
[music]
[applause]
washing
[music]
and
I understand there to this day they ask us
[music]
while the glass is
still like this
[music]
just a few hours ago,
accordingly, he called an emergency
meeting due to another aggravation in
but the rabbinic region over the past day in the
area of ​​​​the place in the seaport,
shots and explosions of artillery were heard
on this the first case of the use of heavy
weapons in the blockaded territories,
the record expressed serious concern on this score,
but the Russian authorities once again
assures the world community that the situation
is under full  control, however, the
command of the UN peacekeeping forces
present in the region are skeptical of
similar measurement example
[music]
[music] [
music]
[applause] [
well
[applause] [music] [music] [
music]
[applause]
[music]